we are one last game let's talk battles
in one you might be wondering why I'm up
here again
well my journey with battlefield started
over two decades ago when dice was still
a small indie studio we were dreaming
about conquering the world and sharing
our games with more and more players now
I've been involved in each every part of
this series and it's humbling to serve a
battlefield community today that has
grown to more than 60 million players
around the world that is truly
incredible so thank you it also means
that we have a great responsibility to
deliver on the promise of battlefield
with every game we have to take creative
risks to pioneer so we knew from the
start the battlefield one could be no
ordinary game now let me tell you a
quick story about the inception of
battlefield one a few years ago two guys
in our studio in at dice in Stockholm
Stefan Stromberg and Martin Copperhead
kept telling me that they had the
concept for the next battlefield and
each time we met they showed me more and
more ideas from the team now I'll be
honest I was skeptical I was like really
skeptical and I told nothing I don't
think we have it yet but they kept
pushing they kept coming back and then
one late night in Stockholm they brought
me a very special pitch an absolutely
mind-boggling pitch unmistakably
battlefield and set in a very unique
take on world war one right then and
there that's when we knew we had to make
this game so when you stand here
introducing a game like Battlefield one
two tens and millions of dedicated
players you know the risks were worth it
you're gonna get us all killed
so that was just a piece or a a play
trailer and you'll get to see the full
version in just a bit but first I want
you to know that our team a Dyson
Stockholm has huge ambitions for battle
one we've set out to deliver an epic and
unforgettable experience for our players
and the result is a dynamic experience
where no battle is ever the same but as
a talented as our dice team is it is you
the battlefield community that powers
the team that is why at world premiere
last month we revealed battle 1
alongside our players we want the
community to be part of this every step
of the way and today marks another
exciting milestone in the road to bat
field one our first in-depth look at
gameplay and to reveal that I'm honored
that we have players from our community
here to lead the first ever live stream
of battle one immediately following the
press conference and our host Jose
Sanchez is with a few of them right now
thanks guys I am excited because today
we are going to see actual gameplay
straight from battlefield 1 under the
command of two solid teams with players
like Jamie Foxx Zac Efron are going to
be on those team are you guys pumped for
tonight's event yes jazz can't wait dude
Stoke I know I'm excited and coming up
in a few minutes we have the battlefield
squads live stream kicking off 64
players going head-to-head 32 V 32 in a
best of three matchup and I can't wait
to see wins good luck to the both of you
guys and your respective teams now let's
go back up to Patrick and find out
exactly what makes this game so epic
Thank You Jose so only in battle one
really engages some of the biggest
battles ever seen as you scored up in
epic multiplayer matches with up to 64
players now that's going to be really
cool to watch and in just a few minutes
you'll get to see how no battle is ever
the same through the power of frostbite
intuitive destruction dynamic weather
and a variety of weapons and vehicles
makes this the most immersive and
dynamic battlefield game ever so let's
start by talking destruction a hallmark
for battlefield in battle one
destruction is more intuitive and
natural than ever
this creates unlimited gameplay
possibilities as you impact the world
around you a next dynamic weather
weather we now change unpredictably so
you can you will need to adjust your
tactics based on the conditions so
playing the same map on a bright day or
in heavy fog or rain will impact what
you see or hear so you have to adapt
your playstyle and finally an impressive
variety of weapons and vehicles add to
the range of experience you'll have in
the battlefield and most notable the
introduction of the ultimate vehicles
that the hemas the great war gave birth
to some of the largest vehicles ever
made and battle one gives you the chance
to control these beasts take control of
an airship armored train or a battleship
to dominate the battlefield across air
land and sea and all-out war has never
felt so epic when bastard Juan launches
on October 21st worldwide you will
experience destruction weather and a
variety of weapons and vehicles that
ensure no battle is ever the same and
for those of you who are battlefield
insiders you get an early access to
experience this firsthand during the
open beta later this summer all right in
just a few minutes the battlefield
squads livestream will begin but first
let's take another look at that field
one thank you
yo Joe mind you're gonna get us all
canned
hey boy
okay okay
you